we have been programming devices we've
been programming mainframes we've been
programming pcs we've been programming
the web and so on I think we need to go
to the extreme craziness and think that
the wall is one big computer I think
this is the big North Star goal that we
have you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using dr. Donald
Kaufman is a distinguished scientist who
thinks big and as the director of
Microsoft researches flagship lab in
Redmond it's his job to inspire others
to think big to but don't be fooled for
him thinking big involves what he calls
thinking backwards a framework of
imagining the future defining progress
in reverse order and executing against
landmarks along an uncertain path on
today's podcast
dr. Cosman reflect on his life as a
database researcher and tells us how
Socrates an innovative
database-as-a-service architecture is
Rhian visioning traditional database
design he also reveals the five
superpowers of microsoft research and
how we can improve science with
marketing that and much more on this
episode of the microsoft research
podcast
[Music]
Donald Cosman welcome to the podcast
thanks thanks for having me I like to
start by situating my guests it's such a
researchy term and you are very
impressively situated here so as a
distinguished scientist and the director
of Microsoft researches redman lab what
do you hope to accomplish here what gets
you up in the morning so what gets me up
in the morning are the people I'm
working with an incredible group of
people researchers engineers designers
testers program managers biz op er
Asians people they are all amazing and
it's an incredible privilege to be given
the opportunity to to be their advocate
on the research front what gets me up is
democratizing technology
I think banks have democratized money
and and they've made it for everybody
possible to have money to grow money
cars have made it possible for everybody
to move around in the world all right
that is the pocket izing mobility so
databases which is my background has
democratized data which has made it
possible for everybody to get the best
value out of their data if I want to get
value out of my data I need to get the
tools to get the value if we kind of go
back to the metaphor of a bank right how
do I get value out of my money from a
bank is also that I combine it with
other people and the bank pulls it and
makes out of the math something better
and bigger and then lets me participate
in that so my data my genome data alone
is not very useful but of a large
population of people pulling this
together correlating it with things that
happen that is actually very valuable
and I think what we need to still do and
that's where democratization needs to
happen is that I as the owner of my data
need to control how it is used and how I
get the value back and at the moment we
have just way too few offerings for that
yeah how does the cloud change that
well the cloud at the beginning is just
like a bank it's like a vault where you
put your data and it's also kind of the
opportunity to do something with the
data so it is a platform that then
allows everybody at some point to kind
of realize their visions and their
dreams on what to do with data and how
to create value with that data prior to
MSR you had a lengthy a notable career
in academia I'm gonna ask you more
specifically about your life in your
path to MSR later but I think it's worth
talking briefly about your time as a
professor at ETH Zurich were you for a
database person in the computer science
department tell us a little bit about
the history of database systems and what
the landscape looks like now in the era
of cloud computing one of the things I
always say jokingly about databases is
the databases are boring and hard and
that's why they make so much money
nobody wants to do the boring stuff and
nobody can do the hard stuff so it's
kind of a good combination but
essentially database is a fairly old
technology but it has always been about
three things one thing is value how do
you get the best out of your data which
is what are the features that you
provide the power of querying the data
of updating it of correlating it and
doing things with the data the second
thing has been security how do you make
sure that the data stays under your
control that you own it and determine
what happens with the data and the third
is I would call it cost or performance
is making sure that you don't overpay
for the data right that it's kind of
cheap too or kind of gets more and more
affordable to do what you want to do
with your data and control it all right
so what did you do as a database
professor so one of the waves I was very
involved in was the so called semi
structured data wave the best way to
process data is if it's really
structured and you know exactly what it
is right and you have a schema
essentially and I spend a lot of time
working on semi structured data which
has some structure that you kind of
extract and that is kind of like
getting good value out of all data not
just your structured data like your bank
accounts but also your email the books
you write the Word documents you write
getting some value out of that so that
was a big phase of mine another big
phase of mine was distributed databases
and how to optimize them and how to make
them perform in a very scalable way all
right so that's kind of three waves
you're riding is there anything that you
see out in the ocean right now that's a
way of coming in that the database
people might be facing and new
challenges that research could address I
think it's still about value as security
and cost and will always be in the
database world but I think what we've
seen of the generations or the eras of
computing is this pendulum and we
started with a mainframe computer which
is kind of very centralized then we got
into the PC area which is kind of
decentralized where you push to the
customer then we went to the web which
is again centralized we went back to the
mobile phone and smartphone which is
decentralized then we went to the cloud
which is again logically centralized and
now we're hitting back again in this
pendulum to what we now call the edge
and I think we haven't in databases even
started to think about the edge because
the edge for us is kind of like 9
billion new machines and nobody has
thought about deploying databases on
nine billion machines we're now at
hundred thousands or ten thousands of
machines in the cloud but nine billion
is yet a totally different thing how are
you even thinking about that well of
course again my mental framework is
pretty much always the same in on the
technology side value security and cost
but the best way to think about it is if
you believe in this as being the new
machine or so what is the killer
application what do you want to do with
this data at the edge and whatever
constraints so one way to do research is
to look at what is happening today and
think of one assumption that is going to
go away right oh that is add it but
usually it's an assumption that goes
away of course it has to be driven by
some application
so now if the assumption goes away it's
centrally managed what can you do with
this data now if you have such a system
and then that kind of inspires you to
think about how to build such a system
before you put on your visionary leader
hat I know you were a lot of hats around
here Donald I want you to tell us about
some of your own research let's start
with cipher base which is a sequel
database system that stores and
processes strongly encrypted data tell
us about cipher basin how a database
professor got involved in cyber security
and cryptography
when I was at ETH in the late 2000s I
was working with several companies among
others I was working with the Swiss
banks and so there was actually a very
big scandal in Switzerland and that is
that the German government paid one of
the Swiss database administrators to
produce a CD of all German customers
that had bank accounts in that back and
of course the assumption was those were
all tax evaders and most of them were so
the problem with that was that in
Switzerland this is illegal but in
Germany it's actually totally legal so
what happened is that the Swiss bank
came to me because it was a database
administrator and I was a database
person they came to me and they said
okay Donald how can we prevent that that
never happens again
and that kind of created my interest
into encrypted databases or protecting
data from the administrators but still
letting the administrator do their job
they do a lot of important things with
the database but they don't have to
really look at the data right the
business needs to look at the data but
not the database administrator and so we
developed a bunch of technology and we
worked on that for two or three years
and at some point a distinguished
engineer from Microsoft visited ETH and
he came to me and we talked about what I
work on and I told him that story and he
said Oh actually we're at Microsoft very
interested in that problem and so I
visited Microsoft and MSR and I learned
about their solution and it was actually
much much better than what I had thought
out over three years the DTH so I said
oh this is great I want to work with you
and
the birth of the cipher based project
and that's what then later on became the
always encrypted feature of sequel
[Music]
traditional database architecture has
some significant limitations when it
hits the cloud and one of the most
exciting projects that you're even
currently involved with is an answer to
that
it's called Socrates that's the kind of
setup I want you to unpack expectations
versus reality with the move towards
database-as-a-service paradigms in the
cloud and how this new architecture
compares with the older what you call
monolithic database architecture I think
this question is best answered if I give
an analogy and that is retail there's
the brick-and-mortar retail and then
there's the online retail and both are
important just like both database
architectures will that be important but
they were designed with different
assumptions and different goals in mind
so the brick and mortar we want to kind
of minimize the movement of goods so you
go there you try your new fancy suit on
it fits you go home you have almost zero
returns because logistics are expensive
right it is also about a kind of very
specific experience that people want to
have it is all together so this is what
traditional databases do they are
designed for a particular experience and
having a particular assumption so moving
data around is expensive and the
experience is when I do a query to a
database I want to immediately get the
answer and I want it to be fast now
let's go to online retail online retail
it has this big logistics problem but it
has some other features right
essentially you have virtually all
products in one hand at one fingertip
and if you think about why online retail
is so
cessful is because it is cheap right
that's what got people hooked up there's
low-cost and why is it so cheap
because it never wastes any resources if
you look at a shop there are people
working there that sometimes there are
no customers and they are just wasting
resources if you think about an online
retailer there are no wasted resources
all the workers are constantly working
and active there's nobody standing
around and the same happens in the cloud
and that is essentially the Socrates
architecture it is really designed for
not wasting any resources and that's our
kind of goal in the cloud to drive down
cost and that's why we separate the
resources and you just use resources and
put them together as you need them
alright so I want you to tell me a
little bit more about Socrates
technically and how you have achieved
this reduction in cost and increase in
efficiency with the architecture that
Socrates presents yes so essentially
what it is all about is separating
concerns or disaggregating so
traditional databases are monoliths all
functionality is kind of intertwined and
mingled together but very highly
optimized to have that experience just
like a shop what Socrates does is it
essentially separates compute storage
and the log essentially it separates
concerns to make sure that we can
optimize and can utilize these concerns
in the best possible way when we talk
about disaggregation we typically talk
about this aggregation of computing
resources and when we talk about the
architecture that does it we talk about
decomposing it into many services so
there's a mini service that runs queries
there's a mini service that logs all the
updates that happen and then there's a
mini service that serves the data in the
retail environment there's a mini
service that gives you the catalog and
presents the goods to you there's a mini
service that is the warehouse that ships
the products to you and then there's a
mini service that does the payment and
it's kind of like the analogy here I
right so where is this in the pipeline
because we've got huge legacy systems
and now you've got this new idea that's
optimized for the cloud in some sense
the good news is that we don't have to
change the API another analogy is if you
buy an electric vehicle you don't have
to relearn how to drive no if you've
changed the engine and you've done
something really big underneath and
that's one of the big achievements of
the engineering effort of Socrates is
that we didn't change the API so it's
all under the hood failure has many
faces and not all of them are ugly
you've had some experience with failures
sometimes you even called it miserable
failure so tell us about some work that
you've done that didn't work out and
what lessons you learned while you were
at it my favorite story is that of a
failed startup so I've also done
startups that's kind of for me as part
of the academic experience that you do
startups and I had a grandiose failure
of a start-up I'm not laughing at you
it's actually fun now it was a little
bit less fun at the time so in 2006
Amazon kind of started with the cloud
and I started a company that built a
semi-structured database for the cloud
and it was a semi structured database
because I've been working on semi
structured databases and it was the
cloud because I thought the cloud was
really cool and was going to be a game
changer and I wanted to be the first
there the problem was that these were
too big bets it was a big bet on the
cloud and was a big bet on semi
structured data and if I had just made
the cloud bet I would have been great I
mean the ideas of separating compute and
storage that's exactly what I did at
that time and the semi structure that I
think it's still going to pan out it's
still really important it just didn't
pan out at the same time and with the
startup if you make two beds they need
to all pan out at the same time and
that's just not gonna happen right so
bet on one miracle rather than two or
three finding the one miracle that is
the art of doing a start-up but also
doing a
research project let's talk about
superpowers you wrote a blog post which
I loved where you compared and
contrasted superpowers of academia of
product groups of startups and Microsoft
Research so give us a superpower
breakdown of these various institutions
and entities and where you land
personally on what we might call the
value proposition of Microsoft Research
essentially the what I believe the five
superpowers that the company gave us
this is really when Bill Gates kind of
founded Microsoft Research this is
freedom we can freely collaborate with
everybody in the company we are not tied
to any organizational structure the
second one is we have time we don't have
product deadlines shipping deadlines and
so we have time to really think things
through the third one is we take risks
we can fail fast
we don't have legacy if we find that an
idea is stupid we just kill it and we
just stop working on it right this is
different for product groups creativity
is a big part of our culture we generate
ideas constantly this is kind of part of
our job and the fifth one is we build
stuff we execute and of course we do
that with the product groups right and
so coming to your question I think every
kind of organization has a different mix
of these I mean
academia is creative our product groups
are creative that startups have some of
these but this combination is unique and
so if we want to innovate which is kind
of our mission and what we want to
achieve that's how we create value to
the company we have to use these five
superpowers we were talking about some
projects like always encrypted or cipher
base that's exactly something that
academia cannot do because academia
doesn't have the execution part they
just don't have the resources to do it a
start-up cannot do it either because
these project takes time and the time to
do this a start-up just doesn't have and
so that's what we're looking for and
it's actually amazing in this time how
many projects
really need exactly this combination of
superpowers there's been a long-standing
debate between what I might call pure
research purists and another group that
I would call team tech transfer who are
entrepreneurs and the argument stems
them around to the purpose of research
and how you measure it and one side is
always yelling science and the other is
always yelling impact but you've
actually argued that the argument is
becoming moot why well because it's both
right and so I would have to kind of
drill down a little bit what I think a
good research project does and it has
essentially three components it has
scientific insight I had some idea of
some secret sauce the second piece it is
has an execution it executes on
something it creates something and the
third one is I call it marketing but
what it really means is having clarity
on the impact and the interesting thing
is that the execution and marketing make
the science better I cannot explain it
but it's happening right now when we do
science and we execute that actually is
a feedback loop to our science we see
things that we wouldn't have seen if we
hadn't executed on it or the creating
the clarity on how this is going to
change the world makes us kind of
question assumptions that we might have
not done if we had just stayed in the
scientific world and actually makes the
science much more interesting this is
what I find so amazing about the job
that I have and about Microsoft Research
if I see how researchers kind of get
this inside and they say yes the
execution makes my science better and
the impact makes my science better this
is kind of like really deeply gratifying
[Music]
most people think somewhat logically
that in order to innovate we need to
think forward or think ahead and you
suggest in another provocative blog post
then we actually need to think backwards
tell us what you mean by thinking
backwards and then unpack why we need to
do it why it's hard to do it and what
happens when we do it yeah so I wrote
this blog post as a reaction to comments
that I heard often well we'll cross that
bridge when we get there and often what
happens is you never get to that bridge
or when you get there you're really
stuck unprepared and you don't know
what's going on so what thinking
backwards does is it starts with what we
call it microsoft defining a North Star
goal a really good North Star goal and
then not immediately jump oh what is the
best direction to that North Star goal
but kind of creating landmarks and I
call them landmarks because milestones I
kind of like forward thinking about
someone what is your milestone one but I
actually think about landmark n minus
one because really what we do is we
navigate uncertainty we don't know where
we will go but if we know oh there is a
somewhere there I need to get there I
don't know exactly what will happen on
the path but I know the dimensions I
know I can go west and east I can go
north and south I know essentially how I
can maneuver and if I know them
landmarks right then I can get there and
if I do get stuck it kind of helps me
not to get frustrated so if I know this
is my landmark and I get stuck I hit a
dead end which happens to all of us I
will find a solution to get to the
landmark or I will redefine the landmark
it gives me much more clarity to deal
with these situations whereas if you
move forward and you hit a dead end
you're stuck and then you often give up
and you get frustrated
well Donald we've reached the part in
the podcast where I always ask my guests
what could possibly go wrong and I do
this because every line of research that
has potential for great good also has
potential for great risk or great harm
and as a leader you don't only have to
worry about your own stuff you have to
worry about the stuff of all the people
that you Shepherd and supervise so what
if anything keeps you up at night
metaphorically and what responsibilities
do you have to identify and then try to
mitigate the potential risks of the work
that you do and the work that the people
here do so as a high order bid I'm an
optimist and I just well move forward
we're just talking about thinking
backwards but actually I always think
there is a way out and one of the
reasons why I think that is because in
the bad situations I have been in life
there was always somebody with me I've
always managed to never be alone because
if things get bad it's much better not
to be alone I have also I have this I
think one of my biggest strengths is
that I can detach myself from myself so
sometimes if things go really wrong I
can look at myself and say well Donald
you really screwed up okay and then I
have a different perspective and it
helps me to move on in microsoft
research we are about risk-taking we've
created something called failure to
lunch which is a seminar series where
people of the lab talk about their
failure and we celebrate the kind of
what we call smart risk-taking but
usually there's something to be learned
and we celebrate failure and that is
great all right so let's move over and
not talk about failure let's say that
you succeed wildly in some of these
technologies that you're chasing that
are your northstar goals and they have
unintended consequences how do you
mitigate that that of course is a great
question and I think when I started
computer science we were innocent I
remember writing grant proposals and the
question about ethical concerns it was a
no-brainer and now everything we do has
an ethical side we
dealing with technology that is
dangerous and we know it right it can
all be misused in many ways as
scientists we have a responsibility to
think about how our technology can be
misused and we have a big big
responsibility to educate society and do
our best to explain the technology and
possible misuses of technology if we do
that we kind of do the right thing and
we also play our role it is not our
decision how our technology is used we
just need to be responsible and develop
technology that makes the world a better
place we should think about the positive
sides but again I'm an optimist all
right it's story time we've heard a bit
about your academic and professional
life let's rewind a bit and hear how you
got there how I got into computer
science is not a heroic story I didn't
know anything else what to do
it's kind of more random and then really
by design I come from a family of
lawyers and so I wanted to always to
become a chartered accountant which is
also I mean database is just as boring
as that and and so I went to the Harvard
summer school and I did a course on
programming and it just infected me I
got the bug and I loved programming and
so that kind of changed my plans I
studied computer science and I think I
just got lucky
so from there you went to be a professor
you got a PhD somewhere in the mix there
your professor at ETH Zurich connect the
dots for us here's the story right so I
had been working on this cipher based
project with MSR and probably I was
somehow on the watch list and I had
visited and I got an offer to join MSR
and for me it was actually pretty clear
that I would decline the offer
unfortunately not for my wife or
fortunately not for my wife so my wife
literally said Donald you can stay
happily Sen al at ETH or you can start
from scratch
and I thought well actually both of
those options are pretty bad right I'm I
don't want to start from scratch but I
don't want to be sent out either and so
what we ended up deciding that I stopped
from scratch because why have one career
if you can have two careers and so now
I'm in my second career I started from
scratch and has been quite a ride
tell us something interesting about
yourself that we might not know whether
it's a characteristic a life event a
sidequest something you've done and how
it is affected or impacted your life or
career and if it didn't even affect
yours
maybe somebody else's one thing I did
this summer I wrote a small book it's
called Vonda and farm attic the miracle
of computer science so I actually wrote
it in German because I have four
children three daughters I wrote it
essentially for my daughter's because
they're kind of asking me all these
questions why did you study computer
science how did you get there
and I never had a good answer I felt
like I was old my way through a whole
career as a professor without knowing
why to study computer science or why I
was so lucky I had to reflect on this
and what is it that makes computer
science so special I wrote it I
evangelize it a little bit in
Switzerland that's why I wrote it in
German because I was invited to give a
commencement speech at one of the high
school in Switzerland and that was kind
of I used that opportunity to kind of
appetize the book and so I got a lot of
feedback from that it has been great
because as it always is when you teach
you learn more than anybody else right
we've talked about the importance of
thinking backwards and establishing
northstar goals maybe you could give our
listeners a little primer on how they
could go about setting their own
northstar goals including what they
should do if they run into one of those
dead ends that you talked about earlier
what I believe my biggest problem as a
lab director or as a researcher is
defining the right goal that is the
biggest problem of all essentially it
defines our ambitions getting the right
level of ambition and
rising because the opportunity is rising
that's a very difficult task for a
researcher so I think that the thinking
backwards framework is actually great to
define a North Star goal and to get to
the right level of ambition and the way
it works is if you don't find a path
backward from your goal to where you are
your ambition is probably too high right
starting civilization in space right
it's probably too big of an ambition
because we cannot execute on it but if
you kind of have not interesting
landmarks if they are boring if they are
not inspiring you then your ambition was
probably too small and so the framework
allows you to first of all reason what
your goal is and kind of dream of it and
the implications that it has and the
impact but it is also a way to kind of
keep you honest and validate things as
we close I want to give you the last
word and as the leader of the MSR lab in
Redmond you're in a unique position to
offer some advice and inspiration to our
listeners what's the next big North Star
goal for Microsoft Research yeah so of
course now I have to think big and I
have to think beyond to be inspiring so
I think we have been programming devices
we've been programming mainframes we've
been programming pcs we've been
programming the web and so on I think we
need to go to the extreme craziness and
think that the world is one big computer
I think this is the big North Star goal
that we have and I think to break it
down and we were talking about the edge
and the cloud we are kind of making the
world programmable by injecting
computers or microcontrollers into
everything and that way we make the
world programmable but at the moment we
are still doing that in isolation and I
would love us to think of it as a one
big system that we should program and of
course we should think about again what
are the things that we can enable what
are the killer applications of that
computer what are the ways to optimize
kind of in the same way as Socrates how
to secure it if everything is connected
how do you draw lines and essentially
how to program it in an efficient way so
that everybody can take advantage of
this walled computer again it ties into
our superpowers we have the freedom to
work on this we have the skills to
execute maybe not on the complete vision
but on pieces important pieces once we
have clarity about the landmarks we have
time to do that we can take risks right
some of the things will fail on that
path we have all the ingredients here
that you need to address these really
really big dreams
Donald Kaufmann thanks for taking time
away from your own North Star goal and
coming in thank you so much to learn
more about dr. Donald Kaufmann and how
thinking backwards is moving us forward
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]